obviously you've been a part of
launching two two of the I mean Market
one and two talking about Power 105.1
real 92.3 each against the biggest
Heritage hip-hop stations in the country
yeah
if I mean what were some of the bumps
and bruises for each City because
obviously it took you a few morning
shows to land on The Breakfast Club yeah
it helps if you're in LA and you launch
with big boy absolutely
um what were some of the bumps and
bruises where you kind of had to like
because again like there's no rules for
each City you got to kind of like learn
on the flyer I'm sure for each station
that you launched because you've
launched so many power with power was
different in that you know I was again I
I was like two three years into the job
but I mean my team respected me but I
also was the only black person and the
only New Yorker right that was involved
in the equation so sometimes you just
gotta you gotta muscle your way in and
like now we're gonna do it this way
right now that way because we're all
type A personalities
um and then once we launched
um my mindset was I was gonna bring
different people in from different radio
stations that I oversaw to put them on
the air hindsight that was a mistake
okay I think
it's got to be people from that City
yeah to to make it work because it's
it's a lot or at least predominantly
predominantly absolutely it's a local
radio station so it should be people who
live and breathe and eat and sound like
that city
um and I think I made the mistake then
and that's not casting [__] on anybody
there right but I think in the best
interest of the radio station and I
think I learned that here in La like you
you know people got to be from here they
got to be able to talk and sound and you
know and and speak the language of the
city
um launching with big was obviously a
it's like a cheat code huge Advantage
for us we wouldn't have done it if we
didn't so yeah I think that people don't
understand there would not be a real 92
3 if I heart hadn't have napped big boy
it wouldn't have been worth going
against him no I didn't think we were
going to do it honestly I remember when
we first when Tom first reached out and
said hey you know I think this could be
the play and this is like in 2014 I
think I had met big in maybe 2008 when
we were considering syndication with him
and I come out to LA and one of the
things I knew about him is he was
incredibly loyal super loyal guy great
incredibly loyal I'm like unless they
really really messed up he's not leaving
and
um I never forget I was in it was late
December
might have been the first week or two in
January 2015 I'm in New York in a
meeting with 50 Cent get a text on my
phone
like yo we're ready to go
got it done I gotta get on the phone I
gotta negotiate my new contract with my
boss did that in like five minutes and
then because at that point in time
you're realizing you're moving to La
yeah had to let my lady know by the way
um I think we're going to be moving to
La she's like let's go you know and uh
and excuse myself in that meeting with
50 I'm like yo I got to get on a plane
and go to LA tomorrow go find a place to
live and get ready to launch a radio
station then my next call was the AO who
I had just made the PD in Miami yeah hey
I know you really really like Miami oh
he really likes Miami yeah it's
legendary Right he and him had an
all-nighter with him don't ever hang out
with hey yo he'll kill you um I was like
hey man what we uh why don't you come
with me to L.A let's do this and he was
like yo let's go yeah yeah that's my God
man no it's crazy because
um
like you said like it was like a very
last from what I understand the whole
well first of all there was like a
lawsuit right with with involving big
leaving right yeah so I remember you
telling me like hey man
we're in the middle of this legal ship
with big boy
so if you're if you gotta you gotta get
out of your deal they have to let you
out we can't like yeah I wasn't I wasn't
because I was like dude I could just
quit and then pop up in that light
you're like no not this he's like this
big [__] wasn't happening maybe but and
big wasn't big wasn't the only one there
were there were a couple people that I
had
um I had interviewed who I wanted to
bring on a team who were working in
Television right and they were the
mindset oh yeah I could do a different
medium I could do both right I'd be like
no you got to get approval like no no
they're good I already spoken to him
about it and just like you when they
went hell no nah not doing it and they
were they were blown away and I'm like
there's nothing we can do about it but
yeah I know for me moving forward it was
never again because in some instances
and I know in in one deal in particular
I actually said okay let's put the deal
in front of you and then you can take it
to your boss as opposed to you getting
permission first and the boss said no
yeah I had a meeting with uh some
redneck guy from Beasley and Orlando
love Orlando because he he was like I'm
I told him yes yeah he's like we got to
go sit with I think it I forget the you
know those beasleys are from like
Augusta Georgia or some [__] yeah and
the guy was like you know you're gonna
regret this I gotta say you're number
one right now yeah can't just let you go
tie to our heart poaching our talent
yeah yeah so it didn't work out but